c'est l'image qu'on se fait de singapour
capitale financière une ville moderne et
riche mais le singapour des résidents
c'est ici qu'il se vit dans les
quartiers de logements sociaux
80% des singapour hier réside dans ses
et du débit flat comme il les appelle
toutes familles dont le revenu annuel
est inférieur à l'équivalent de 185
mille dollars canadiens petit résider
idées y aident à grandir ici il apprécie
l'aspect communautaire
et
il avoue aimer un peu trop l'air de
restauration du coin on compte plus d'un
million de logements sociaux construits
par le gouvernement à singapour
ils ont remplacé les bidonvilles et les
habitations insalubres dans les années
60 et sdb fondamentaux et n'a rien
organizing ces habitations ont été au
coeur de la modernisation rapide du pays
la demande reste trois fois plus élevée
que l'offre mais pas de guerre de prix
c'est le gouvernement qui établit
l'ordre de priorité des acheteurs
hidayet tu pourra emménager dans son
propre appartement lorsque la
construction sera terminée dans deux
formules à qui
il a été jugé prioritaire puisque c'est
sa première propriété et que ses parents
vont déménager dans le même complexe
grâce au programme incitatif
multigénérationnel
il recevra même de l'aide
gouvernementale alors jusqu'à 50000
dollars pour son logement de 360 milles
dollars de l'eau à midi une grande
famille aso à proximité du livre
singapour s'est récemment lancé dans le
logement social de luxe c'est ce qui
menace l'accessibilité pour les jeunes
créé cet architecte
japonais
car l'état tient compte de la valeur du
terrain dans son prix de vente et il est
donc victime des fluctuations du marché
privé les prix de revente ont d'ailleurs
augmenté de 10% en un an et demi et le
gouvernement a dû imposer à la mi
décembre des mesures pour freiner la
spéculation est d'ailleurs lui a juste
hâte d'avoir sa première propriété avec
sa conjointe et leurs deux enfants il
suffit du club la radio canada singapour